this is the Terran one the first rocket
that's almost entirely 3D printed it was
built by relativity space a startup that
is developing a new potentially
revolutionary way to manufacture Rockets
using the biggest metal 3D printers ever
made when I started the company I
thought there was a 50 50 chance within
three months we figured out 3D printing
a rocket was just not going to be viable
at all although relativity has made
impressive strides in the field of 3D
printing it's never launched a rocket
into space a notoriously difficult feat
for any company let alone one that uses
an untested manufacturing method yet
that lack of a track record hasn't
diminished customers interest as the
date of relativity's first launch
approaches the company says the Terran 1
is one of the most pre-sold rockets in
history before launch
today's global commercial space industry
is estimated to be worth over 350
billion dollars weightlessness
oh geez although space tourism gets most
of the headlines it's only a tiny slice
of the overall Market compared to
satellite manufacturing and services
which make up almost 50 percent of the
sector according to a Citigroup report
the satellite Market could more than
double to 697 billion dollars by 2040.
three two one to cater to this growing
demand for satellites a crop of private
Aerospace startups have begun developing
new technologies to drive down launch
prices and capture a share of the market
relativity space which was founded in
2016 by rocket engineer Tim Ellis is one
of the most closely watched companies in
the launch sector the first week of
starting the company and actually the
first email I sent from my relativity
space email account was a cold email to
Mark Cuban we were raising about half a
million dollars asked him for a hundred
thousand dollars and then I think about
10 minutes later he replied back and
said he would give us the entire thing
from those auspicious Beginnings
relativity expanded rapidly to include
over a thousand employees and multiple
production test and launch sites across
the country relativity is also just the
fourth company to ever receive a
dedicated launch pad at Cape Canaveral
for the past 60 years rocket
manufacturing has relied on a
labor-intensive and time-consuming
process involving the Assembly of
thousands of parts by hand we have
traditionally sent Rockets into orbit by
designing them very carefully on the
ground and going through several
iterations of every single component of
the of the of the rocket starting from
the engines all the way to the design of
the vehicle itself and Rockets work at
the limits of their capabilities and
that's why it takes on so long
relativity is looking to shake up that
traditional model by using Advanced 3D
printers and artificial intelligence to
produce rocket engines and other complex
Parts in 60 days rather than years
this is our second generation printer we
have a third generation that's about
twice as big as this and then a fourth
generation that's even bigger than that
so this one's an older version but it's
still one that we're using to produce
flight Hardware actively
traditionally the different metal parts
of a rocket have been assembled together
by shaping milling and welding but at
relativity Engineers program a robot
printer to deposit layers of the
company's proprietary metal alloys one
on top of another so we have our own
Material Science team that develops our
own custom aluminum Alloys which is how
we can 3D print a rocket that's strong
enough and has good enough quality we
use a combination of plasma Arc
discharge and lasers to melt and then
collect data on this aluminum wire as
it's fed into the print head at the end
of a robot arm to optimize its Rocket's
designs relativity leverages algorithms
and machine learning to refine each
iteration since you're 3D printing it
you can build almost anything the the
computer algorithm comes up with so you
do much like nature end up with these
evolutionary looking Parts It's really
because it's it's a computer algorithm
using physics to determine what the part
looks like
[Music]
so this is a dome for the new rocket
we're developing Terran r
an R is the second rocket relativity is
developing compared to its smaller
cousin the Terran 1 which has about a
2700 pound payload the Terran R has a
payload capacity of about 44 000 pounds
relativity says it expects to launch the
Terran R in 2024. we intentionally have
this very wavy pattern so that makes it
much stiffer it's really starting to
show with 3D printing what you can do
that you really cannot do traditionally
with normal manufacturing building
something like this it would be very
challenging you would have to have a
massive press and then you also couldn't
vary the thickness of the Dome and all
the different locations easily like
we've been able to do here so we really
can cut out quite a few steps by
printing something like this so really
3D printing and the approach we're
taking is going to get even better the
larger things that we build
rocket manufacturers have typically
relied on complex Supply chains in which
different parts of the rocket are made
by different subcontractors relativity
turns that model on its head by bringing
everything in-house with a vertically
integrated supply chain intended to make
the company a One-Stop shop for sending
Rockets into space we had to
simultaneously build a brand new
manufacturing technology the world's
largest metal 3D printers and build our
own rocket we have our own rocket
engines we develop our own flight
software all the electronics and
computers that control the rocket the
structures the test site the launch site
but the advantage of that is there
really is not off-the-shelf technology
you can just go buy and plug in building
everything from scratch lets us also cut
cut out kind of middlemen as far as
suppliers and other other companies that
frankly would just slow us down
relativity isn't the first rocket
company to incorporate 3D printing into
its manufacturing process but when it
comes to 3D printing and Rockets no
other company matches the ambition of
Relativity according to the company the
Terran one is 85 3D printed by mass for
its next rocket the Terran R
relativity's goal is for it to be 95 3D
printed by Mass
year relativity announced it was also
planning to launch the first commercial
Mission to Mars in 2024. it's a really
ambitious but important Mission and
despite the private space industry this
year being two decades old there's
really only two companies SpaceX and now
relativity that that are working on this
mission
relativity's biggest test today is
expected to take place in February when
the company will attempt to launch the
turn one into orbit rockets work at the
limit of what is possible to do with
materials and when we introduce a new
manufacturing technique which is what
has been done by using 3D printed we
introduce a set of unknowns and
challenges so it remains to be seen if
this technology actually will be able to
substitute what other Manufacturing
Technologies can do a successful orbital
Mission would not only prove that a 3D
printed rocket can reach orbit it would
also demonstrate that relativity's new
3D printing technology can be used to
build reliable cost-effective Rockets
this is going to be a big rocket